it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we show you some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts so start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com to get what you need
lifestyle expert Elizabeth Warner joins
us right now hello
I'm gonna feed you this morning
stress now doesn't come doesn't come
with the actual cooker here but these
pockets are going to completely
transform the use of your slow cookers
your pressure cookers so when we
actually cook inside of them sometimes
we have to make a whole lot of food
right we end up throwing it out or maybe
you have kids that eat different things
well now we're going to be able to use
that slow cooker and make two totally
separate dishes so while you're doing
that maybe you know you're having a
party you've got a couple of dips like I
have right here and easy cleanup if
you've ever used a slow cooker the whole
idea is set it and forget it it's
supposed to make life easy but at the
end of the day Everything Burns and
cakes on the side then I'm scrubbing and
I'm a little irritated washed right out
right exactly it's a hundred percent
silicone it's BPA free it's FDA approved
by the way do not accept any substitutes
you want to stick with this brand
because you know that it's FDA approved
and it's bpa-free you're getting all of
these yeah exactly
59.95 for the entire bundle it's 25 off
except no substitutes this is amazing
Snips is one people need to understand
that that's right they got to do two
whole Cycles right exactly and then you
end up wasting food okay so this is
called key smart ipro okay first of all
it's a way to organize your keys up to
14 keys can fit inside of here you just
open it up add them in the inside it
also has a bottle opener a flashlight
because you know when you get home at
night you can't see but the best part is
that you can utilize this with find my
app so on your iPhone you know find me
if you've done this you've done it
before well now if you misplace your
keys you can go into your find my me app
on your iPhone push a button and it'll
chime on here so you can find your keys
you can also push a button on here when
you use your phone and it'll help you
find your phone and the best part is if
you start to walk away with your phone
and you don't have your keys your phone
will time to let you know that you're
walking away from your keys so you can
never lose your keys again so this is
the keysmart I Pro it's 34.99 30 off if
you don't have an iPhone don't worry we
have the pro available on cbsdeals.com
and that works with the tile that's
great so there's one for everybody final
opener comes standard appreciate that
kid yes because you know you know all
right so yes security every four seconds
in the United States a house is
burglarized I worry about that but I
also worry about my kids getting home
from school my parents coming home from
work this is the Bell and Howell video
doorbell and chime the chime goes inside
the house so when somebody Rings your
doorbell you're actually going to be
able to hear that doorbell exactly so
with this it's a it's a 1080p high
definition camera so what that means is
nothing is grainy you're actually going
to see great video this has LED lights
so at night time when it gets dark
you're gonna have a great picture anyway
it has motion detection so if anyone
walks in front of it it'll notify you on
your phone if someone rings the doorbell
it will notify you on your phone and
it's got two-way talks so I could be
sitting on my couch and not really want
to get the door I can talk to them but I
could also be on vacation far away and
they think I'm at home so this the
security is amazing how much is it this
is yeah so right now sorry it is 99.95
50 off wow that's a great long battery
life
that's right and it also holds an SD
card inside for to hold everything so
you don't have to subscribe and put a
price on safety exactly is all that
memory being used up on your phone with
pictures and videos you go to take that
picture you got a solution exactly this
is Click free on this you're going to
see that there are four sides that's
because it's designed to go into your
iPhone your Android your PC or your Mac
you insert this download a free app and
you're going to be able to take all
those pictures and videos off your phone
or device and save that memory yes
monthly charge exactly and then think
about this
photos that you have sitting in a box or
an album you can actually insert this
into your phone it's got software in it
you can then scan those pictures they
will become digitalized and you will
have those memories forever you won't
ever have to we brought this back it was
so popular second opportunity
50 off
99.99 bring this to a wedding take a
bunch of pictures and hand it over as a
gift or take it to a birthday party
speaking of birthdays
[Applause]
with all these companies to get these
deals to buy anything that you saw scan
the QR code on your screen or go over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now